entre second débat dans ce sens public
consacré au conflit en Ukraine à ses
dizaines de tonnes de blé bloqué dans le
port de dessin une arme pour Vladimir
Poutine une menace de famine pour
certains pays notamment dans le Maghreb
au Proche-Orient et une carte
diplomatique à jouer pour la Turquie le
pays qui se pose en médiateur Marion
Delpech
Sergueï la roche réitère son engagement
sécuriser les navires exportant les
céréales à condition que la marine
ukrainienne des mines les eaux alentours
mais sans fournir de mécanismes concrets
nous sommes prêts à assurer la sécurité
des navires qui quittent les ports
ukrainiens et se dirigent vers les
détroits nous sommes prêts à le faire en
coopération avec nos collègues Turcs
alors que la Turquie médiatrice jugent
légitime la demande de lever les
sanctions sur les exportations agricoles
russes l'Ukraine refuse de son côté de
déminer le port d'Odessa pour permettre
la reprise des exportations elle craint
que les forces russes n'en profitent
pour attaquer la ville et fait peser sur
l'agression russe la pénurie de céréales
nous avons équilibré mis fin à leur
discours selon lequel les sanctions sont
responsables de la crise alimentaire
nous avons communiqué activement le
président et moi-même sur la véritable
cause de cette crise l'agression russe
pas les sanctions le blé reste donc au
tâches de la guerre 22 à 25 millions de
tonnes aujourd'hui bloqué 70 à 75
millions de tonnes pourraient être d'ici
l'automne selon le président
ukrainien le secrétaire général de l'ONU
alerte une fois de plus sur les
conséquences du conflit 3 mois après
l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine nous
sommes confrontés à une nouvelle réalité
pour ceux qui sont sur le terrain chaque
jour et synonyme de nouvelles infusions
de sang et de souffrance et pour les
populations du monde entier la guerre
conjuguée aux autres crises menacent de
déclencher une vague sans précédent de
fin et de misère laissant dans son
sillage le chaos social et économique
pour atténuer la crise des efforts
concrets doivent être faits pour
garantir que les approvisionnements
essentiels en nourriture et en énergie
parviennent au plus vulnérable fait
valoir l'ONU
le chantage au blé la situation
militaire dans le Dombas le rôle
diplomatique d'Emmanuel Macron beaucoup
de thèmes à aborder dans dans ce débat
avec mes invités Irina nutrishing
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes maître de
conférence à l'Institut national des
langues et civilisations orientales
responsable des études ukrainiennes
Bertrand Bady bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
professeur des universités en sciences
politiques et en relation internationale
à Sciences Po auteur de puissance
mondialisée repenser la sécurité
internationale livre publié aux éditions
Odile Jacob j’accueille également
Christian maccariian bonsoir Christian
vous êtes journaliste spécialisé des
questions internationales et
chroniqueurs international au point
Laetitia croupety qui est resté à mes
côtés donc je commence par le blé Irina
mitrychin la Turquie n'était pas à cette
à cette réunion l'Ukraine n'était pas
assez réunion en Turquie est-ce que ça
veut dire que que dans votre pays dans
votre pays d'origine on en attendait
rien cette réunion où est-ce qu'il y
avait quand même l'attention des médias
ou du public tourné vers vers Ankara
parce que la première question à se
poser est-ce que le crâne a été invité
donc on pourrait commencer par là je
n'ai pas entendu du refus de la part de
l'Ukraine ça veut dire que cette
rencontre avait été conçue comme une
rencontre bilatérale sachant que le
crâne n'était qu'un des aspects il y a
eu d'autres sujets qui avaient été
discuté et donc ceci explique peut-être
cela effectivement est-ce que on est
plus
Bertrand Bady dans une sorte de
communication diplomatique plutôt qu'une
vraie recherche de solutions je reste
toujours sur cette cette rencontre
d'Ankara oui vous avez raison la
communication est devenue un aspect de
plus en plus important qui a toujours
été mais qui est de plus en plus
important dans la gestion si vous me
permettez cette formule de la
conflictualité internationale tandis que
et je crois qu'il ne faut pas l'oublier
c'est important pour notre analyse la
négociation dont tout le monde parle et
quelque chose d'un peu obsolète
c'est-à-dire regarder les guerres qui se
sont succédées depuis 1945 elles ont
rarement presque
on va dire ça comme ça plus
qu'intéresser puisqu'il a un pied dans
chaque partie il a aidé considérable en
l'Ukraine en lui fournissant des drones
très performants
aux forces russes et puis l'autre pied
de la Turquie se trouve clairement du
côté de la Russie puisque
la Turquie discute avec la Russie de la
situation de l'Ukraine afin que entre
autres choses elle a essayé à plusieurs
reprises de joue un rôle cette Turquie
mais entre autre chose afin que les
céréales puissent sortir du CREL mais ce
que propose les Turcs est quand même
relativement hallucinant il propose que
des convois maritimes quittent au dessin
que tout soit à sa déminé avec l'appui
de la marine turque qui
incontestablement sait faire cela donc
déminé ensuite ces navires chargés de
céréales sur la cheminée jusque dans les
détroits qui appartiennent légitimement
à la à la Turquie et puis la Turquie au
total serait acheteuse en tête de ces
céréales mais sur lesquels elle
obtiendrait 25% de discount donc si vous
voulez elle négocie sa ristourne c'est
comme on a l'impression que la Turquie à
chaque étape
dramatique et de cette crise absolument
catastrophique et c'est de retirer les
marrons du feu exemple quand la Suède et
la Finlande ont voulu rejoindre l'OTAN
la Turquie a essayé très vite de s'y
opposer d'y mettre son veto en tant que
membre de l'OTAN pour
exiger que la Suède expulse les
représentants du pkka qui sont réfugiés
à Stockholm à chaque étape on dirait que
la Turquie s'arrange pour profiter de la
misère du monde de la misère de
l'Ukraine pour essayer de retirer un
prout petit profit un petit pourboire
c'est le parti indépendantiste du
Kurdistan
que derrière il y a aussi Washington et
là parce qu'il a il y a eu Maduro qui
est réussi était invité il y a donc ce
qui se passe en Syrie et le rôle de la
Turquie veut jouer donc c'était quand
même un échiquier beaucoup plus
important alors il y a quand même une
séquence assez passionnante aujourd'hui
lors de cette visite en Turquie du
ministre SFR étrangères russes il a été
interpellé par un journaliste ukrainien
alors malgré les multiples blocages du
protocole il a réussi à poser cette
question voilà ce qu'il dit à part les
céréales quelles sont les biens que vous
avez volé à l'Ukraine et à qui les
avez-vous vendu voilà ce que réponds
Sergueï la roche
vous les Ukrainiens vous êtes toujours
préoccupés par ce que vous pouvez voler
et vous pensez que c'est comme ça que
tout le monde pense
nous avons expliqué aujourd'hui que les
céréales peuvent être exploitées
librement vers leur destination il n'y a
aucun obstacle de la part de la Russie
une seule chose est nécessaire c'est
l'ordre de Monsieur zeninski s'il peut
encore décider quoi que ce soit
d'autoriser les navires étrangers et
même Ukrainiens entrer dans la mer Noire
Irina nutrition c'est assez conforme à
la à la propagande on va dire de
Vladimir Poutine et de ces lieutenants
depuis le début c'est à dire que ils
utilisent le mensonge et ils accusent
leurs adversaires de ce qu'ils font
eux-mêmes quoi c'est c'est vraiment là
on l'a retrouvé plusieurs fois depuis le
début du conflit et il fallait voir
vraiment à la séquence en vrai parce que
d'abord il est arboré un sourire
vraiment carnassier mais en disant donc
en essayant de déstabiliser bien sûr ce
journaliste ukrainien et on a quand même
tous vu aussi bien ces images de de blé
donc les les bateaux ont été suivis donc
on sait qu'il y a eu des tentatives de
les vendre à l'Egypte au Liban etc on a
vu aussi la télévision russe l'a montré
tout ce qui avait été amené dans
obstacles ces énormes bobines d'acier
qui ont été chargés direction Russie
donc les preuves s'accumulent je ne
parle pas de tous les pillages qui ont
été commis par par l'armée russe et
malgré tout il n'a sans vergogne il
retourne l'argument et prétend que la
Russie et dans ce monde droit et qu'il
n'y a rien en fait
Christian macarian c'est quoi l'un des
plus vieux compagnons de route si je
peux employer cette formule de
l'Alliance Poutine oui il est depuis le
début des années 2000 ministre des
Affaires étrangères 2004 je crois de
mémoire ça fait quand même un petit
moment
ça a été un diplôme extrêmement brillant
je parle au passé on l'appelait parfois
diplomator c'était vraiment le Goldorak
de la diplomatie il impressionne tout le
monde il parle très bien l'anglais et
quiconque a pu le rencontrer ne peut
qu'être impressionné par sa connaissance
avec extraordinaire des dossiers etc
mais sur la question ukrainienne c'est
un autre homme on a l'impression que
c'est un perroquet qui répète ce qu'on
lui a dit de dire ce n'est pas
nécessairement sa première spécialité
l'Ukraine c'est plutôt encore une fois
le vaste monde et là on a vu une autre
face d'un lavre suppo du régime en
quelque sorte qui c'est un peu déprécier
d'ailleurs il a il a subi une décote
dans l'entourage de Poutine il n'a plus
la cote qu'il avait donc est-ce que il
essaie de se racheter de se maintenir en
essayant de reproduire la voix de son
maître c'est possible toujours est-il
que il ne pourrait pas soyons soyons
honnêtes être à procéder autrement il ne
pourrait pas faire autre chose que ce
qu'il fait dans ce régime là Bertrand
m'a dit pour caractériser ce conflit
vous parler d'une guerre mondialisée oui
pourquoi alors d'abord pour distinguer
de guerre mondiale vous savez il y a en
ce moment cette tendance de dire c'est
la troisième guerre mondiale c'est le
retour de la guerre c'est le retour de
la guerre froide on ne retourne jamais
en histoire et il faut voir la
particularité de ce conflit par rapport
d'abord à tous ces conflits qui se sont
succédés depuis 1945 et par rapport
justement de aux deux guerres mondiales
quelle est la différence essentielle
c'est que non seulement cette guerre
s'inscrit dans un contexte nouveau qui
est la mondialisation mais il se
caractérise par une
sur-utilisation de toutes les ressources
que la mondialisation peut apporter aux
partenaires et notamment le mode de
participation des États occidentaux à
cette guerre est tout à fait
intéressante dès le début enfin même
avant le début le président des
États-Unis Joe binden a affirmé qu'il
n'était pas question d'aller se battre
en Ukraine mais en même temps on a vu ce
constituer une sorte de pression tout à
fait inédite dans l'histoire des
relations internationales qui consistait
à dire à l'agresseur à la Russie si tu
ne te tiens pas tranquille on te vire du
monde ce qui est un langage tout à fait
nouveau peut-être la nouvelle arme de
dissuasion on verra en fonction des
résultats de cette politique qui se
traduit par une exclusion de l'économie
mondiale mais pas seulement une
excellente d'économie mondiale c'est pas
seulement une économique c'est une
guerre mondialisée ça veut dire exclu de
la culture du sport de des médias du
tourisme de tous les échanges possibles
et imaginables alors évidemment
cette tonalité nouvelle et une inconnue
absolue est-ce que ça va avoir un effet
est-ce que ça va faire long feu on ne le
sait pas pour l'instant pour une bonne
raison c'est que le propre de ce type de
stratégie c'est que son effet n'est
perceptible qu'à moyen ou long terme
vous dites exclus du monde ou exclu du
monde occidental parce qu'on a quand
même vu depuis le début de ce conflit
que la Russie gardait quelques soutien
vous avez raison de poser cette question
parce que le problème de l'exclusion et
que ça marche si elle est véritablement
systémique ça veut dire quoi que il n'y
ait pas de possibilité de contournement
ou de fuite si vous voulez et là on voit
que les fuites entre guillemets sont
nombreuses du côté de l'un du côté de la
Chine du côté des pays arabes peut-être
aussi du côté d'un nouveau Sud dont on
parlera peut-être tout à l'heure mais je
dirais l'essentiel n'est peut-être pas
là parce que ce qui est intéressant dans
une guerre mondialisée c'est le
mécanisme systémique qui se met en
marche c'est-à-dire la caractéristique
inédite de ce conflit c'est qu'il touche
tout le monde y compris ceux qui n'y
sont pour rien et ceux qui sont
totalement à l'extérieur alors
conséquent économique par la
déstabilisation de des circuits de
logistiques etc récemment est-ce que
j'entends des dire en Afrique c'est nous
on est complètement extérieur à ce
conflit mais c'est nous qui allons payer
la facture donc il se crée un jeu
systémique pour le meilleur et pour le
pire le pire c'est qu'effectivement tout
le monde risque d'être étranglé dans
cette affaire le meilleur c'est que
malgré tout cela crée une pression très
forte sur les acteurs et principalement
et c'est ce jeu là qui permet de dire
que la partie est loin d'être terminée
parce que la Russie utilise énormément
le contrecoup
[Musique]
de l'autre il est responsable de l'autre
des principes il y a un principe de
droit et de liberté des peuples à
disposer d'eux-mêmes si vous si vous
mettez dans un plateau la famine de
l'Afrique est dans l'autre la liberté
d'un peuple à disposer de lui-même et la
balance va pencher la réaction de la
guerre dans la réaction de l'opinion
publique notamment et ça indique quelque
chose de tout à fait importante c'est
que rien ne peut être décidé tout seul
c'est-à-dire tout est interactif
l'affaire des céréales est tout à fait
remarquable tout le monde dit c'est pas
de ma faute c'est la faute de l'autre ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que pour
dénouer la question céréalière ce n'est
pas l'initiative d'un des partenaires
qu'il faut suivre c'est la guerre qu'il
faut arrêter c'est la guerre qui est
véritablement à l'origine de tout ça
parce que c'est la guerre qui fait
monter le prix de l'énergie ça c'est la
guerre qui désorganise complètement les
échanges mondiaux c'est la guerre qui
crée des attitudes protectionnistes dans
les économies par exemple l'Inde qui
ferme
donc vous voyez
c'est guerre mondialisé c'est un
phénomène systémique qui n'a plus rien à
voir avec cette vieille image qui nous a
dominé pendant des siècles et des
siècles donnés par le philosophe anglais
hopes au 17e siècle les États sont entre
eux comme des gladiateurs non ce ne sont
plus des gladiateurs c'est une sorte de
mécanique globale qui est exactement
alors deuxième thème dans notre débat la
situation militaire les violents combats
autour de la ville de sévéraudognets que
le sort du Dombas se joue là-bas c'est
ce que disait le président
ukrainien hier
[Musique]
qui sort et donc si la ville tombe les
Ukrainiens pourront se se retirer donc
pour l'instant on essaie tout simplement
de ne rien céder tout en sachant que ce
n'est qu'une ville quand même qui a
détruite déjà tout comme mari ou Paul a
plus de 80 % que le gouverneur de la
région dit que les bombardements sont
constants et que c'est vraiment de
gauche à droite de droite à gauche donc
on il y a vraiment un tapissage et
ensuite c'est les troupes qui montent à
l'assaut et donc s'ils sont repoussés
les bombardements reprennent pour
justement ne pas permettre aux
Ukrainiens d'avoir des positions
rétranchées pour défendre défendre à
vivre parce que pour les Russes
maintenant c'est que l'avancée qui
compte peu importe les dégâts Christian
matériaux le l'Ukraine qui réclame des
armes lourdes longues portées alors pour
pour bien comprendre qu'est-ce que ça
pourrait changer pourquoi ça pourrait
éventuellement inverser le cours de
cette part du du conflit parce que les
Russes s'appliquent une tactique
militaire très destructrice qui consiste
à encercler les villes un cercle assez
lointain d'une vingtaine de kilomètres à
pilonner et à utiliser par adjonction
l'attirer et les bombardements
militaires aériens notamment parce
qu'ils ont une super idée avec des
bombardiers très performants que même
les pays les forces occidentales n'ont
pas donc
ensuite ce cercle se rapproche de la
ville et détruit la ville il s'agit même
pas de prendre des positions ou de
prendre des risques qu'il s'agit de
raser et dans ce cadre-là la
contre-réponse c'est évidemment de
l'artillerie et des missiles et des
batteries antimissiles donc les
Ukrainiens sont légitimes à réclamer
cette aide là simplement
cette aide là si elle dépasse une
certaine portée par exemple les fameuses
batteries de lance-roquette heimars
américaine peuvent dans une version
atteindre kilomètres et dans la version
qu'auvent livrer les Américains c'est
limité à 80 km mais les Ukrainiens
souhaitent que ça puisse aller le plus
loin possible mais ça n'est pas le
calcul des Américains qui craignent que
la longue portée finisse sur le
territoire russe et alors là on
entrerait dans une autre phase encore
plus complexe c'est-à-dire une
déclaration de guerre à la Russie il ne
faut surtout pas que ça arrive donc la
Russie avance pas à pas mais de façon
absolument effroyable c'est-à-dire en
rasant tout le prochain étape si c'est
véreux de net que tombe ici chance juste
après ce qui est quand même du domaine
du possible si ce n'est du probable
après c'est Kramatorsk et ensuite les
Russes descendront au sud et ils auront
fermé la nasse pris environ 100% de
l'eau blast de luansk et il
s'apprendront ensuite à l'aublace de
donner ce que blues au sud après quoi
leur objectif sera atteint peut-être
qu'à partir de là c'est peut-être ça le
point qu'il recherche on pourra parler
de négociation justement mais justement
l'idée des Occidentaux c'est d'aider les
oxydes des
Ukrainiens à arriver à la table des
négociations dans la position la moins
défavorable possible alors justement
Bertrand Badier est-ce que est-ce que
c'est ça finalement le la sortie de
guerre ce qui est horrible pour les
Ukrainiens c'est à dire le renoncer aux
dons
alors comme je le disais tout à l'heure
je ne vois pas un marchandage autour
d'un tapis vert franchement cela ne me
semble correspondre ni à ce que sont
devenus la relation internationale et
les relations conflictuelles ni surtout
à l'état de la société ukrainienne et là
ça me permet quand même de dire une
chose c'est que clairement
Poutine a perdu l'une des trois guerres
il y a la guerre militaire si vous me
permettez cette quasi-tothologie la
guerre sociale et la guerre économique
ou cette guerre de mondialisation dont
on parlait tout à l'heure
Poutine a perdu la première guerre déjà
c'est à dire tout le monde s'attendait
le 24 février à ce que Kiev 2022
ressembla à Prague août 1968 avec une
entrée facile des chars soviétiques à
l'époque et russes aujourd'hui dans la
capitale félon entre guillemets bon ça
c'est terminé donc il a quand même
besoin à de montrer qu'il n'a pas
totalement perdu sur le terrain et donc
il lui est facile de changer sa
rhétorique et de dire nous voulions des
nazifier entre guillemets le Dombas nous
y avons réussi nous le comprenons nous
l'avons libéré et donc il s'arrêterait
de lui-même alors une façon et je ne
sais pas le problème c'est que c'est
bien je sais bien que personne que quand
on prétend sa voix c'est que soit on
écartement sienne ce qui est
parfaitement légitime mais ce n'est pas
mon cas on ne sait pas mais c'est une
option c'est un scénario effectivement
d'arrêter ce qui dans ce cas là d'une
part privé d'une négociation mais ne
mettrez pas fin à la guerre parce que de
même que l'infection de la Crimée n'a
pas interrompu ce long processus dans
lequel l'Ukraine est engagée dans la
guerre simplement on serait dans un
scénario de pose c'est-à-dire une sorte
d'armistice sur des lignes de front et
puis ensuite
il adviendra ce qui pourra il faut quand
même
maintenant une phase de dissuasion c'est
à dire la société résiste je vais leur
montrer ce que ça coûte de résister et
la destruction devient une nouvelle arme
c'est la destruction pour détruire
décourager dissuader des moraliser un
dernier mot là-dessus Irina et puis
ensuite on passera à la diplomatie
française et à Emmanuel Macron mais
effectivement on voit s'il Dombasle
tombe ça veut pas dire pour autant que
l'Ukraine va y renoncer vous voyez ce
que je veux dire tout à fait mais
surtout qu'il y a plus que le don de
base il y a il y a aussi le sud tout le
sud toutes ces villes de Herson mes
collègues donc je mets les tops pardon
qui ont été qui ont été prises et qui et
où on fait maintenant une rucification à
marche forcée l'introduction du rouble
les écoles tous les systèmes qui
repassent donc aux normes russes on
parle de l'organisation d'une sorte de
référendum ou une façon de rattacher ces
territoires à la Russie et qui ne serait
pas le dombasme qui serait rattaché
d'une autre manière administrative
peut-être avec la Crimée donc
plus parler que du don-bass il y a quand
même déjà ça a largement débordé ces
régions là on va parler diplomatie
encore avec le rôle de la France donc
Laetitia question qui revient souvent
quand Emmanuel Macron ira-t-il à Kiev
l'invitation du présidentiel remonte
elle remonte au mois d'avril en tout cas
avril c'est le moment où volody Meers
qui donne cette interview à CNN où il
dit oui j'ai invité le président
français à venir à Kiev il a une bonne
raison de cette invitation il dit
lui-même il dit pour qu'il vienne
constater que ce n'est ne s'agit pas
d'une guerre mais bien d'un génocide et
vous savez Emmanuel Macron a refusé
ensuite un employé ce mot génocide et
puis on a questionné on sait les
journalistes français à plusieurs
reprises Emmanuel Macron pour savoir
quand est-ce qu'il avait une date est-ce
qu'il savait quand il irait à Kiev alors
la dernière fois qu'on lui a posé la
question c'était la semaine dernière et
puis il a répondu en marge de son
déplacement à Cherbourg en temps utile
dans les conditions utiles je ferai ce
déplacement mais plus important c'est
surtout d'être là de prendre les bonnes
décisions c'est ce que nous faisons
pourquoi n'y va-t-il pas on a
l'impression que le président français
est toujours resté sur cette réponse en
temps utile j'irai en temps voulu mais
ce n'est pas vraiment exact parce que au
départ il l'a justifié le fait qu'il
reste en France parce qu'il y avait la
campagne présidentielle et puis ensuite
élection présidentielle et le 15 mars il
a répondu à des à des réfugiés
Ukrainiens en disant que il n'excluait
rien mais que il a dit qu'il le ferait
quand il considérera qu'il peut y avoir
un résultat
utile et tangible et c'est bien cela
Thomas il veut y aller quand il aura
quelque chose à dire à faire en tout cas
pour essayer de peser sur le cours de la
guerre pour l'instant il n'y a rien à
faire donc il reste en France et on peut
dire que le temps presse parce que la
présidente française tournante du
Conseil de l'Union européenne elle se
termine là dans quelques jours la fin du
mois de juin oui il sait qu'il a tout
intérêt à y aller avec cette casquette
là pourquoi parce que dès 2017 il s'est
présenté lui-même comme le nouveau
leader européen de cette Europe
politique il sait aussi que les opinions
publiques ont vu d'autres hautes
dignitaires défilés le Premier ministre
Boris Johnson
Ursula vanne derrière van der layonne je
vais y arriver la présidente d'un
Commission européenne et puis côté
français il y a quand même Catherine
Colonna la nouvelle ministre des
Affaires étrangères qui est parti de la
semaine dernière elle a visité bout de
chat ensuite à la rencontre
c'était le jour de la mort de notre
confrère de BFM TV donc oui il y a
constamment des personnalités du monde
occidental qui se rendent à Kiev oui il
y a d'autres personnalités politiques
françaises qui s'apprêtent à y aller
d'ailleurs mardi Gérard Larcher le
président du Sénat qui recevait le
président du parlement ukrainien a dit
j'irai
quand je vais me rendre en Ukraine c'est
pas simplement pour aller faire un tour
c'est pour être utile
naturellement je rendrai compte au
président de la République avant et
après parce que je pense qu'il y a des
moments où la France va parler d'une
voix et que c'est la responsabilité de
parler d'une voix mais cette voix peut
être une voix aussi qui est une voix
forte il voit qui insiste
c'est important cette cette notion de
voix parce que Emmanuel Macron dans son
équation il y a quand même une donnée
qui est fondamentale c'est qu'il veut et
il a décidé de maintenir le dialogue
avec Vladimir Poutine ce lien
diplomatique qui ne cesse de brandir
comme peut-être un rempart à une guerre
totale c'est ce qu'on entend dans le
dans l'argumentaire d'Emmanuel Macron et
c'est aussi qu'il ne veut absolument pas
entrer dans l'escalade des mots donc il
a refusé de reprendre génocide il a
refusé de reprendre les thèmes de Joe
Biden boucher dictateur concernant
Vladimir Poutine et donc pour le moment
il tente de baliser son futur
déplacement pourquoi pour ne pas que
Vladimir Poutine l'interprète comme une
offense et comme une possible entre en
guerre de la France comment vous merci
Laetitia comment vous analysez
ce refus d'Emmanuel Macron pour
l'instant d'y aller alors il y a
plusieurs lignes de lecture d'abord
Emmanuel Macron a pris la tête d'un
groupe de pays qui sont leaders au sein
de l'Union européenne un savoir trois
pays principalement de l'Allemagne et
l'Italie la France n'est pas seul et je
crois que beaucoup de Français n'en sont
pas nécessairement très conscients
l'Allemagne a exactement la même
position et Rome l'Italie aussi donc il
y a une fracture entre l'Europe de
l'Ouest et l'Europe de l'Ouest c'est
incontestable la Pologne la République
tchèque surtout la Slovaquie la Roumanie
par peur légitime la Bulgarie par
crainte légitime sont sur une position
beaucoup plus dure vis-à-vis de la
Russie et beaucoup plus sportive comment
dire en anglais
vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine c'est clair et
net l'Europe occidentale est sur une
autre ligne ensuite il y a le problème
des de la position américaine il y a eu
des outrances verbales américaines à un
moment l'œil de Sting secrétaire à la
Défense qui s'est rendu sur place et
ensuite en Allemagne sur la base de
Rammstein a dit que il fallait que la
Russie enregistre une telle défaite
qu'elle n'est plus envie de recommencer
ce qu'elle a fait en Ukraine alors là ça
a été immédiatement nié par la Maison
Blanche et corrigée mais enfin quand
même il la prononcé ses paroles là donc
il y a une espèce de ligne de crête que
les Français les Allemands Italiens ne
veulent pas franchir et puis enfin
manuel Macron représente le classicisme
français vis-à-vis de la Russie Jacques
Chirac avait une phrase sur la Russie il
ne faut pas humilier la Russie il ne
faut pas humilier la Russie comme par
hasard Emmanuel Macron a repris la même
un peu plus raffiné mais quand même il a
dit Emmanuel Macron il ne faut pas
humilier la Russie car lorsque les
combats cesseront il faudra trouver un
chemin de sortie de crise c'est un peu
plus fin que il ne faut pas mis la
Russie il a quand même dit aussi il ne
faut pas humilier la Russie donc quelle
est la position de la France et celle de
Macron c'est un peu le en même temps
appliqué aux Affaires étrangères il faut
aider les Ukrainiens autant que nous le
pouvons afin qu'ils arrivent dans la
meilleure position le jour des
négociations la meilleure position mais
il ne faut pas pour autant enfin il faut
pour pour autant il faut être très
conscient que c'est avec la Russie qu'il
faudra traiter au final donc on vise le
stade final c'est dans la phase
intermédiaire en revanche que la
position est très difficile donc ça
explique à mon avis pourquoi Emmanuel
Macron ne sait pas rendu encore à Kiev
parce qu'à Kiev expliquer tout cela
c'est un peu complexe ça va être très
décevant pour Monsieur Zelenski et pour
les ukrainiens et il ne veut pas le
décevoir rien dernier point je tiens
beaucoup à ça très bref c'est Emmanuel
Macron a un projet européen
qui est quand même il a fait des
promesses à la Serbie notamment à
d'autres pays dans l'ordre d'entrer dans
l'Union européenne et l'Ukraine vient
derrière et la France a eu des phrases
très blessantes pour les Ukrainiens je
reconnais mais des phrases quand même
cohérentes sur le fait que l'Ukraine
devait hélas attendre encore avant
d'entrer en ligne dans l'Union
européenne et si vous voulez ça ça fait
que c'est difficile d'aller Acquier pour
bien compris expliquer cela Bertrand m'a
dit en quelques mots c'est la conclusion
de ce débat cette stratégie française
vous la moi ce que j'ai eu du mal à
comprendre c'est pourquoi effectivement
s'il est Laetitia la présidence
tournante de l'Union européenne c'était
quand même une fenêtre de légitimité
pour y aller au nom de l'Europe oui
encore faut-il que l'Europe soit
véritablement uni et je prolonge que
disait Christian macarian il y a un
instant on entend dire couramment ce
formidable en un coup de baguette
magique l'OTAN est ressuscité l'Union
européenne est unique c'est pas vrai ni
dans un cas ni dans l'autre il y a au
contraire des clivages extrêmement forts
il faut voir sur quel ton en Varsovie on
parle de la présidence française pour
bien le comprendre donc je dirais même
que Macron n'est pas dans la position de
Sarkozy qui présidait aussi l'Union
européenne lors du conflit géorgien nous
sommes en 2008 et où là il pouvait
porter un consensus européen il y a ça
qui joue il y a d'autres éléments vous
savez alors la France est deux choses en
même temps c'est savoir faire cavalier
seul pour garder son rang c'est-à-dire
il y a cette idée typiquement typique de
la culture diplomatique française il
faut avoir une position solitaire pour
garder son rang et la raison d'être de
son siège de en permanent du Conseil de
sécurité mais il faut surtout pas
ressembler aux autres mais il y a aussi
ce rêve de tout régler et d'être
effectivement à vous interrompre
malheureusement excusez-moi de vous
interrompre mais c'est l'heure du de
votre flash info en langue
ukrainienne et j'appelle
Steve Jourdain à nous rejoindre de
nouveau rebons sur on commence ce
journal de l'Ukraine avec la visite du
président du parlement ukrainien au
Sénat oui le président de la Rada était
reçu ce mardi au Sénat deux mois après
l'intervention de volodi mirzelinski
devant les parlementaires français
l'entretien entre les deux hommes a duré
deux heures il a porté sur les attaques
russes sur les négociations de paix ou
encore sur l'intégration de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne
l'Union européenne Gérard Larcher a
affiché son soutien à la candidature de
l'Ukraine une candidature qui a été
déposée au mois d'avril et qui sera
examiné les 23 et 24 juin prochain à
l'occasion d'un sommet européen je te
souhaite
l'Ukraine a écrit en lettres de Sonia
et le président du Sénat qui a aussi
annoncé qu'il allait se rendre à Kiev
pas de date précise un concernant ce
déplacement de Gérard Lachaise qu'on
sait ce qu'il devrait durer plusieurs
jours président
initiative de plus à signaler pour les
réfugiés Ukrainiens à Lyon oui la ville
continue de se mobiliser un gymnase
transformé en centre d'hébergement à
reversé portes cette semaine il s'agit
du gymnase Bellecombe situé dans le
sixième arrondissement de la ville
depuis le début du conflit ce gymnase
qui compte 140 litres plus de 7000
unités au total la municipalité
lyonnaise a déployé 150 agents pour y
assurer l'accueil des réfugiés
à la destination des startups
ukrainiennes oui si vous venez d'arriver
d'Ukraine et que vous travaillez pour
une start-up et bien un poste de travail
vous attend à Paris une entreprise a
décidé de mettre à disposition ces
locaux pour accueillir les réfugiés qui
bossent dans la tech il s'agit de
l'entreprise liberté Living Lab ces
bureaux sont situés en plein cœur de
Paris ils sont mis à disposition à titre
gratuit
on termine avec les élections
législatives on vote aussi en Ukraine
pour envoyer des députés à l'Assemblée
nationale en France oui les Français qui
vivent à l'étranger ont voté la semaine
dernière c'était le cas des Français de
la 11e circonscription circonscription
qui comprend notamment l'Ukraine et la
Russie en Ukraine il n'était que 33 à
Kiev sur un peu plus de 400 inscrits à
effectivement avoir déposé un bulletin
dans l'urne je termine en disant il
m'accepter la député c'est la député
sortante lr.e.m ensemble qui est arrivé
en tête Anne gente au deuxième tour elle
sera opposée aux candidat communiste de
la nuque Dominique Vidal
merci beaucoup à tous merci Erina pour
la traduction merci Steve pour ce flash
d'infos à destination des réfugiés
ukrainiens